[Music]
hi
mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a comedy film called the bandit
hound spoilers ahead watch out and take
care
[Music]
bandit is an australian shepherd trained
to be a thief by his masters manny and
willie in the opening scene he walks
into a bank with a bag and a note
attached to it the guard doesn't care to
check the little dog and lets it through
the cashier reads the note that says the
dog is attached to an explosive which
will go off if they do not fill his
backpack with hundred dollar bills she
quickly does as told after which bandit
runs away outside his masters are
waiting for him in a car they check his
bag and throw out a tracking device used
as a trap it turns out that the
explosive was fake used as a way to
scare the cashier while manny praises
bandit for his work willie isn't fond of
the dog they drive back to a warehouse
and start counting the money outside a
policeman arrives looking for the
robbers he holds them at gunpoint but
bandit saves his masters by attacking
the policeman manny and willie managed
to escape while the dog is captured
somewhere else a 15 year old boy named
owen is riding his bicycle down the
neighborhood he is suddenly stopped by a
group of bullies they push him around
and call him names even though owen
tries to befriend them a girl from a
neighboring house feels bad for him and
lets her dog out to chase the bullies
away owen thanks the girl and returns
home to his mother joanne owens father
died a year ago because of an illness
ever since then the family has been
facing financial problems they have
moved to the town in hopes of new
opportunities and to be closer to their
only relative auntie deb now that they
have settled in owen wants to get a pet
dog joanne is skeptical but she cannot
say no to her son in the meantime manny
and willie are tense because they can no
longer make money manny wants to get
bandit back but willie insists he train
a new dog he even steals a dog but manny
refuses to train anyone other than
bandit he gets on his laptop and
searches all the dog shelters in the
town only a few minutes in he sees that
bandit is being held in the heart rescue
dog adoption center owen and his mother
get to the shelter before them auntie
deb thinks bringing a dog home is a bad
idea but joanne insists on fulfilling
her son's wishes the owner of the
adoption center trevor is a friendly man
who seems to be interested in joanne he
introduces owen to bandit and the two
instantly get along a while later the
family brings bandit home after they
leave manny arrives at the shelter and
asks to see bandit when he discovers
that he has already been adopted he goes
through the adoption forms and finds out
owen's address he plans to get his dog
back one way or the other at owen's
house joanne and deb discuss the
family's financial issues deb wants
joanne to borrow money from her but
joanne wants to do everything on her own
bandit hears the word money and is
instantly alerted yet he refuses to come
out from under the bed owen tries to
bribe him with toys and treats but the
dog still doesn't move he thinks that
bandit doesn't like him but his mother
asks him to have some patience after the
family goes to sleep bandit finally
comes out from under the bed and runs
outside at the same time manny and
willie arrive there looking for him
manny sneaks inside the house through
the pet door while bandit runs away to a
nearby restaurant the guests think he is
cute and let him play around but when
they are busy bandit steals money from a
woman's purse and returns home on his
way he also steals from a homeless
person back at the house the robbers
drive away after looking for bandit
everywhere but not finding him the
following day owen takes the dog to a
vet to make sure he doesn't have any
illness the doctor checks him and
confirms that bandit is healthier than
ever everything goes well until they
leave and the doctor notices his wallet
is missing that afternoon owen is
playing with his toys in the backyard
when the girl who saved him from the
bullies approaches him she introduces
herself as lily and asks to be his
friend the two chat for a while before
she leaves
later owen and bandit are returning from
the grocery store when the bullies stop
them again they make fun of owen and
snatch his bag of groceries bandit sees
a 20 bill inside their bag and steals it
without anyone noticing when the bullies
threaten to throw stones at them owen
takes a stand for himself and hits them
with tomatoes back at home joanne is
crying because she had a
miscommunication at her job and got
fired on her first day auntie deb and
her husband try to console her when owen
arrives at the house although joanne
pretends like everything is going great
in front of him owen understands that
his mother is having financial
difficulties suddenly bandit hands him
the 20 bill he had stolen from the
bullies before he can figure out where
the money came from someone rings their
doorbell it is one of the bullies and
his mother complaining about someone
stealing his lunch money they also
accuse owen of hitting the kids the
woman threatens to call animal control
and leaves owen realizes that his dog
was the one who stole the money the
following day they go to the park to
train owen firmly believes that what
bandit did was wrong and wants him to
learn to choose dog treats instead of
money while he is at it lily comes to
talk to him along with her dog lucy the
two decide to go on a date to see the
christmas decorations around town after
spending the entire day together and
having a lot of fun they hug and return
home the following day joanne goes to
the dog shelter to meet trevor she
initially wants to talk about bandit's
relationship with her son but the
direction of the conversation changes
when the real dog is revealed and trevor
mentions he wants to date her
joanne is unsure because she has never
been with anyone other than her husband
but she agrees to go out on a date
anyway somewhere else owen is training
banded in a park bandit notices a van
and follows it to the bank two policemen
are loading the van with money from the
state's treasury the dog hides under the
vehicle and steals a bag of money when
no one is looking while he is running
away one of the policemen named albert
sees him but doesn't think much of it
soon they realize a bag is missing and
begin to search for it meanwhile owen
finds banded under a bush with bundles
of money although the kid knows that
taking the money would be a crime he
does so anyway to help his mother on his
way back home he meets auntie deb who
hands him an envelope with a check for a
thousand dollars she asks him to hand it
to joanne as an early christmas present
from her side back in the bank detective
decker is assigned to find out where the
money went albert claims that it might
have been stolen by a dog while everyone
laughs the detective believes him since
he also worked on the last robbery that
bandit was a part of upon reaching home
owen tears the check and puts a couple
thousand dollars in the envelope instead
joanne thinks that her sister is trying
to help her like always and keeps the
money the following day owen decides to
return the money without being caught
but after seeing the news about the
stolen money on tv he gets scared and
changes his mind when his mother asks
him what is wrong he makes an excuse
saying that he has to go out on a date
with lily can't talk mom too busy
pimping after the interaction he goes to
lily's house and asks her out somewhere
else the robbers also see the news and
figure out that bandit has stolen the
money they decide to get it from owen
before he is caught that way the blame
will fall on the kid and they will have
the money owen and lily go to a candy
store where he buys her a lollipop the
other kids surround him asking him to
buy one for them as well to impress lily
he agrees to buy them everything they
want the girls who used to ignore him
before start to flirt with him much to
lily's annoyance he brings the entire
group to a toy shop and buys them
everything they pick lily asks him if he
can afford it to which he smugly replies
that it is his money lily is unsettled
by his new personality but doesn't say
anything outside the toy store a couple
stops to play with bandit but he steals
the woman's necklace and runs away at
the same time albert recognizes him and
starts chasing the dog eventually the
couple and all the kids follow bandit
manages to fool them and gets away after
hiding inside a photo booth back home
joanne and trevor return from a date and
are about to kiss but are interrupted by
bandit soon the truth comes out and the
family is brought to the police station
along with the dog a policeman
interrogates them and asks them if they
have the money while the others deny it
owen realizes his mistake and hands the
bag of money to the officer he decides
to let the family go since they had no
part in the robbery however he has to
hand bandit to animal control where he
will soon be put down owen and bandit
share an emotional goodbye before
separating he returns home sad that his
best friend is about to be killed trevor
tries to cheer him up by claiming that
he can choose any dog from the shelter
however owen knows that no one can
replace bandit at night joanne comes to
his room to check on him and finds him
asleep but owen had only been pretending
he has decided to go to animal control
headquarters to release his dog he packs
up his bag with clothes and other
necessities planning to move to a
different state with bandit as owen is
about to leave lily stops him outside
the house owen thinks she is about to
tell everyone but in contrast she wishes
him luck and kisses him on the cheek
following that he cycles to the
headquarters and swiftly releases bandit
from his cage but what he doesn't know
is that manny and willie are waiting for
him outside ready to kidnap the dog when
owen tries to scream they abduct him and
bring him to a warehouse they had hoped
to get the money that bandit had stolen
from the bank and are disappointed after
finding out that owen returned it so
instead manny leaves willie to look
after owen and goes to rob a bank with
bandit the next morning joanne goes into
owen's room to wake him up only to find
him missing in the meantime manny poses
as blind and enters a bank with bandit
he uses a guard's gun to threaten the
cashier and asks for money bandit and
the cashier go to the vault to fill up
the bag when the dog returns with the
money he and manny drive away back in
the warehouse owen gets his hands on a
gun and threatens willie to go to the
police
just then manny and the dog arrive at
the place on seeing willy trying to
attack owen bandit jumps on him they
struggle and the dog is shot in the
process the policemen come to the
warehouse at the right time and get the
dog to a vet meanwhile manny and willie
drive away while being pursued by a
police car they are happy that they at
least have the money but soon realize
that bandit fooled them instead of the
money the bag is filled with sticky
notes in the following scene owen is in
the hospital praying that the dog is
alive the doctor comes outside the
operating room and gives him good news a
few days later the town's mayor honors
bandit and owen for their bravery and
helping the police to capture the
robbers they are given ten thousand
dollars prize money each the entire town
praises them for their bravery in the
final scene we see that bandit and
lily's dog have made several puppies
together owen and lily sell the puppies
to people in a yard sale
remember kids the moral of this story is
that crime definitely pays you just have
to find a sucker to take the fall for
you
[Music]
subscribe for more videos like this
thank you for watching